we just thought if our American stars
you know do a cotton accent so these are
a cockney expressions Eastern
expressions but written phonetically
okay
so you will get it as we go along so
them if you want to read if you write
the other way on the screen alright so
if you read this phonetically it you
should sound like an sender if you get
them they're good okay this is very good
try this try this one
right this one Jamie you got there's any
copies in the house it's best call we've
got that yeah yeah yeah you could so but
try to shine outside court to pander
hope and hope and hope it's cheese call
painted with fries you can edit we don't
know what kind of it okay depend
quarter-pounder poor panel would quote
unquote Manticore panel with brass it's
like you live in the eastern wall first
okay here's this is another girl that's
another good one try it try this one
Cameron how much is it it's about 750 is
it how much is it that's the same can we
say in Long Beach how much is it one
last word rusher what are you love
Russia a cockle where sandwiches Oh
this is or libraries all over it good
Jeremy doing one more time what behind
me do not mine
yummy yummy
that one there in an adult situation so
if they don't like my language then
don't show up again we're in
effect
won't you take your